Hello, I’m Carla Hayden, Librarian of Congress, asking you to join us
in the nation’s capital for the 17th annual National Book Festival
on Saturday, Sept. 2nd at the Walter E. Washington Convention Center
right here in Washington, D.C.
Dozens of best-selling authors, poets and illustrators will speak, sign their books
and interact with their fans. Among them:
Kate DiCamillo, J.D. Vance, Melissa De la Cruz, Scott Turow, David McCullough,
David Baldacci, Ernest Gaines, and
NASA astronaut, Leland Melvin.
Visit the festival website for a complete list of authors.
The National Book Festival is one of the nation’s premiere literary events
and you don’t want to miss it either in person
[applause]
or online.
For the first time, all of the Main Stage author presentations
will be accessible to you on Facebook Live.
How awesome is that?
But in addition to great authors, there’s much more – bigger and better kids programs,
including favorite storybook characters,
regular story times, games and live music;
family-friendly activities on the expo floor,
a behind-the-scenes look at the workings of
the world’s largest library, the Library of Congress.
Thanks to our amazing sponsors and partners,
this remarkable event is all free to the public.
Come out and support reading and literacy and have lots of fun doing it!
See you there!